Smouse Cobra when it spirit back welcome
to another episode of the Stanley
parable are you ready to get your mind
blow to watch the intro I suggest you
click there for the intro cuz I don't
feel like what's showing it every time I
it's gonna get bar so we're gonna do
another ending now all of his co-workers
were gone what could it mean I'd stand I
decided to go to the meeting room
perhaps he had simply missed a memo so
we are going to all right let's do
everything he says that would wouldn't I
leave it let's do the opposite of
everything he says let's do that alright
that should definitely give us a
different any where the [ __ ] am i that
money is sweet sweet ass young no matter
how hard Stanley looked he couldn't find
a trace of his coworkers can I scan my
butt hole it's like what you did back in
the day now there's just like all these
apps snapchat but no but that where the
hell is the meeting room how are we oh
oh my bad my bad
it's getting lost everything nice when
Stanley Kerr got a set of two open doors
he entered the door on his left alright
so let's go through the door on the
right
hahaha everytime of the correct way to
the meeting room and standing you it
perfectly well or perhaps he wanted to
stop by the employee lounge first just
to admire it the employee lounge sure is
a oh is it simply ah
yes truly a room worth admiring it
hasn't only been worth the detour after
all just to spend a few moments here in
this immaculate beautifully constructed
room
Stanley's simply stood here drinking it
all in but the drinks aren't working
they're not that they're not working yes
really much really worth it being here
in the room a room so utterly
captivating that even though all your
co-workers have mysteriously vanished
here you said looking at these chairs
and some paintings but the chassis worth
it
but the chairs are amazing look at this
day
look at that chain like a this day all
right about the last point Stan his
obsession with this room another party
on his overall personality it's possible
this is what everyone probably 125-foot
for Jane quite a hell of what is this
what is this back in my day I sat around
waiting for more dialogue but when a
long time had passed and there was no
more he decided that the game was trying
to send him a message
Yolo what just happened but at last he'd
had enough at the amazing room and took
the first open door on his left to get
back to business
yes of course back to business the door
on my left nope not today sir yes Stan
Lee was so bad at following directions
it's incredible he wasn't five years ago
this sign is stupid this sign is wrong
it's trying to create a paradox but I
don't think of wearing its architect
sure that looks pretty dope okay let's
move on we're not doing as he says [ __ ]
the guy what's the main [ __ ] big brother
what is this do not jump from the cargo
lift while it is in motion will cause
death penalty for misuse of cargo lift
penalty for jumping sure you have to pay
$5,000 if let's try it
she retired me I think perhaps we've got
enough on the ropes he goes to prove
that he is in control of the story and
no one gets to tell him what to do Stan
Lee left from the platform and plunged
to his death
uh-huh job Stan Lee everyone thinks you
are very powerful thank you thank you
never the end is never the end all right
okay sorry about that
already this was uncomfortable and
Stanley decided that as soon as he found
a new space he felt safe him that he
would never leave it again in his life
wait is this sorry continues from there
why gone I don't know what this game is
so charming I love it and I love the
interaction between the player in the
story Stanley came to Italy well perhaps
he wanted to stop by the employee lounge
first just to admire it we gonna cheer
in for pressing space yeah
years ago Stanley's in depth now [ __ ]
founded for misuse of cargo what is
misusing me okay let's get on the Left
sorry by that uh what it's miss you
hello look Stanley I think perhaps we've
gotten off on the wrong foot here well
I'm not your enemy really I'm not
I realize that invested in your trust in
someone else can be difficult but the
fact is that the story has been about
nothing but you all this time wha really
I was in the middle of siddur a ssin for
others I'm sorry convinced that I want
something bad to happen to you why I
don't know how to convince you of this
but I really do want to help you to show
you something beautiful let me prove I
can amend any prove that I'm on your
side give me a chance
what died okay so that there seems to be
a lot more ending in this game but
that's cool
I'll try them all out and or whatever I
prove it [ __ ]
Jesse [ __ ] tears [ __ ]
what is this no listen carefully this is
important
Stanley walked through the red door now
guide oh god well I did say I was gonna
do everything they did he said what you
can do how to do so let's go through the
red door just getting blue door just
kidding skinny just kidding just kidding
ah ah life huh what a happy
misunderstood Stanley walked through the
red door are you sure about that what if
I'm colorblind
huh what are you gonna do huh what are
you gonna do by the children God WIC ha
ha ha ha that's that I walked through
the red door there's still a blue heart
there is still a lewd art we're going
with the blue door alright fine go ahead
Stanley you want to know so badly what's
out there you want to find out what lies
at the end of this road you've chosen
well don't let me stop you
hey this is this is my favorite when
when you do everything he says you don't
you're not supposed to do you see oh
yeah there's nothing here I haven't even
finished building this section of the
map because you were never supposed to
be here in the first place
Oh dad broken rooms exposed developer
textures is this what you wanted was it
worth ruining the entire story I had
written out specifically for you ill do
not think I put a lot of time into that
because I did and in the end it was all
for nothing
because this is what you wanted to see
helped me here Stanley helped elucidate
these strange and unknowable desires of
yours what would have made this game
better unique I want to see vehicle yes
skill tree yes work with me you give me
absolute ly nothing so far
he sounds like Voldemort let me take a
stab in the dark at a new design and you
can give me some feedback ok there we go
oh good option this already feels leaps
ahead of where we were before God Evelyn
ed Stanley take it for a spin
feeling what aah
but yeah what somebody so many options I
don't know okay hey guess who's going in
here huh hey okay I'm going to stop you
there
now tell me about any experience with
this new version would you say that the
game benefitted from allowing you more
choices feel free to be honest I'm
looking for some real critical feedback
here all right you know why I would rate
an one but that would be mean so I'm
gonna rate it - oh well now this is
useful you didn't like it but you didn't
totally hate it either yeah if you
enjoyed it perhaps is the correct term
it didn't cause you excruciating pain
big steps we've made here today Stanley
yeah based on the data from your
previous playthrough I've compiled a new
version and to be perfectly candid I
think I've knocked it out of the park
with this one let's take a look what the
[ __ ] is he talking about what what
leaderboard there's a leaderboard what
am i good old Neil [ __ ] that guy where's
pewdiepie where's beautiful Oh God
goddamn it where am I wait wait gosh
darn it we're in the last plays aren't
we [ __ ]
well [ __ ] why not ask some brothers what
should I do I'm obviously doing Arab
come on
did uh huh three we'll play she's the
blue toy really oh that's me thanks
thanks how long does it take you to get
to correct or completing it shut up [ __ ]
you
I'm going I'm going here this is my room
[ __ ] you in your blood would you say
that competitive leaderboard helped you
feel motivated to keep walking through
doors again honest answers please
well I would say yes
but I think he's [ __ ] with it so I'm
gonna say no Hey I nearly forgot I've
got a prototype of a new game I've been
working on and now now lovely
opportunity to give it some play testing
you wouldn't mind taking a look at it
but I guess it let me boot it up by the
[ __ ] pony game again I mean a Unicode
sigh why in this game yes the baby
crawls left towards danger oh now you'll
click the button to move him back to the
right and he reaches the fire you fail
it's very waiting yes all about the
desperation and tedium of endlessly
confronting the demands of family life
now our age-old art world will really
take notice but of course the message of
the game only becomes clear once you've
been playing it for about four hours
okay so why don't you give it four hours
of play to make sure it's effective I
won't ought to keep notes on your
experience
don't worry Joel oh no Joel what are you
doing
I think God's sure will you know and
stop John yes okay thank God Joe well
Joel don't know there to fire Joel how
many times do I got to tell you don't
gonna fight so what stop it stop it
why are you so suicide
oh my you gotta do it in my name
stop no no no no no no no god I hate you
don't know why are you doing this
fire equals bad yo how many times I
gotta tell you dole you son-of idea how
many times I gotta burn well fine
go in see if I care hey yo so much why
don't you go dance Thome [ __ ] [ __ ]
bird you kidding oh god ah fine fine you
know what fine burn for hours funky
heartless bastard [ __ ] you you do it
because you hate babies or purely to
spite me matter what I don't know what
to do I'm completely out of ideas I
can't think of a single thing that might
improve the experience for me maybe the
graphic is going to try I'm out I'm out
I'm done it's over thank you for playing
your input was extremely valuable
oh hey since my game was so awful why
don't we play someone else's game just
to ease the pain let's see don't don't
be colorful yeah don't be column dudes
mm-hmm don't they call them dudes
this seems like it'll work don't be
calling them sure what what is going on
here this is way more mine mine cart
well Stanley is this any blank crowd
loves desired name I had absolutely
nothing to do this
I don't know what tell me that stone
will it ever be enough I'll say this I'm
done making things for you from now on I
will only create to fulfill a greater
artistic purpose watch this Danny I'm
going to build a house superb in red
ribbit Oh Kailyn my mmm-hmm
this will GU ya know right here
and there uh this is legal let's see
what does it need I yes of course and
just to finish it all off yes
oh my gosh completes I made this Stanley
look at it gaze upon my work of art and
feel a shame that your own inadequacies
my very first micron level clay you've
only seen it from the outside all then
you gotten half the experience please
step inside and make yourself
comfortable
I can't wait to go inside uh oh my god
isn't it grand
isn't it perfect its it could only be
better if wait that's it we must rebuild
it out of diamond yes of course
diamond everything yes yes yes come
along Stanley we have to get mining
oh yes where are the cows I'm gonna [ __ ]
the cows I mean no I thought I thought
that was you do what are you doing
minecraft oh it has it awesome move I it
looks like it's going to get a bit dark
you brought a light I did not did not
but you can make it out of coal in some
wooden sticks Dex whatever well I see no
no no no no this is far more open-ended
than I had in mind I'm looking for
something more narrow and linear
something that makes you feel utterly
irrelevant this won't do at all one out
of five oh [ __ ] he's mad hymens couldn't
save this one okay new game now I was
enjoying the maket when not you sly
[ __ ] that's so cool that's
actually I'll are they actually gonna be
other games
thank you never net what is this portal
yes we don't even know what this game is
but I love it
what you trapped in a glass box where we
are listening to me Torgo it's inspired
I couldn't have done it any better
myself what is this game even supposed
to be I can't figure it out okay now I'm
curious let's go find out what the hell
this is what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
that's going on this is the most awesome
ending ever
where's my portal gun any my cubes
critical thinking Stanley this is yes
yes this is just you are not know what I
think that's plenty
no now my poor knowledge to see you
stumbles on any one of these games
beta the hell what the hell okay
yeah I know what I don't know what's
gonna happen if I walk down here and
fall down
what what we're back in the original why
I know these texts yes that's this is
too much going out right now for me to
[ __ ] have any clue what's going on
Jesus Christ what the hell this all
started because we didn't do what Ali
wanted us to do
Oh some light that means we should go
towards it I think what do I know has
your mind been [ __ ] in this episode
yet I feel violated uncle we're back in
the beginning what the hell yeah you're
blue
no he's a faction Ambler I think my it
it's a sty there's this exact I wonder
what he found if what he wanted was to
be the leading man in his own story well
perhaps he's gotten it down in wherever
he is right now I wonder if he's happy
with his choice yeah and if he's learned
the heavy cost that comes with it no I
have not understand soon what I was
trying to tell him he needs me someone
who will wrap everything up at the end
to make sense out of the chaos and the
fear and the good few through them
that's who I am
that is what I mean to this world oh yes
yes I'll be back there's no other way
once this ends after it all comes to a
close then I'll be back okay now you can
wrinkly hear some very sudden I can wait
alright so that was another ending huh
that's pretty [ __ ] weird ending I've
weirded me out a lot
ah okay I can't wait to see what else
we're gonna find in this game I'm Way
more intrigued now that I know there's
more different endings so that's cool
hope you guys enjoyed watching maybe
like if you wanted me to do more never
come and tell me what to do and I'll see
you in the next one
stay awesome both of you a belly a
little bit afternoon drowsy I feel like
chambers in it
like take it back that's the kind of
mind [ __ ] we're talking about here